Let's assume we have two different ways to lose weight,
and we want to figure out which one is the most effective.
We have 10,000 people who received Treatment A. Their average loss is 10 pounds.
The standard deviation of their loss is also 10 pounds.
Let's consider a second treatment, Treatment B.
We also applied it to 10,000 people. Our average loss in this case was 20 pounds.
And we also have a standard deviation of 20 pounds.
Our null hypothesis of course is that weight loss from Treatment A equals
the average weight loss from Treatment B.
Our alternative hypothesis is if we are perhaps the providers of Treatment B
is that WB is greater than WA or alternatively that the difference is positive.
With a 5% allowable false positive rate, which hypothesis do we choose to accept?